i think i'm going to start with the most
important question
um ryan has given you some really great
roles the last few years
um what the hell do you buy him at like
the holiday season well
ryan is a man that's i find hard to buy
a gift for
um so because ryan's really good about
you know he's one of those people who
takes care of himself um
but i am not shy with
writing and talking to ryan about
the difference he's made in my both
career and life
um it's it's not
overly common for me to feel a
spontaneous need to reach out
to somebody mid project but
um specifically in the case when we were
working on hollywood
uh it was just some point midway through
where i
i wrote ryan was like i just have to
take a pause to thank you this has
really
already turned into an experience for me
that um
that i think is career and life-changing
and if not either way it's um it's
profound
for me uh i don't know it's it's hard to
know what to say because
so much of that is about
ryan and ryan chooses to be to create
these projects that offer those kinds of
opportunities
and i only think i say is he's kind of
like an angel to me
i'll leave it there um i've been talking
to a number of people in the last few
weeks months
uh and i've been asking everyone a few
of the same questions and i they're
they're
very softball i promise um uh
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
oh uh well right now i'd say succession
i um i think the writing is
brilliant and um
and the acting i the the actors they
have they'd be so wonderful to work with
okay what movie do you think you've seen
the most
tootsie okay uh have you watched any tv
series all the way through more than
once
no okay uh i cannot imagine what it
would have been like to see boys in the
band
off broadway in 1968. it
i can't imagine it have you ever like
envisioned or thought about
being in one of those audiences back
then um has it ever like gone you know
what i mean
yes i do um yeah to me it's one of those
experiences like
people would make up that they were
there just so they could be able to say
that they were because
it was it was such a hot ticket
and you can see photos and read plenty
of essays about
historical essays about it about lines
around the block and the limos pulling
up with celebrities it was just
it was an event and
um you know
what's funny about things like that to
me at least they always seem
preordained in retrospect and
and yet you know very well it's the kind
of thing that
no one saw coming you know and that's
what's so exciting about it is that you
almost feel like you stumble upon
this major moment in in history or the
history of theater or whatever
and um yeah i'm trying to think if i've
been a part of anything like that like
having been in the audience for
something like that i just can't i can't
place it if i have
being a part of that play in 68 could be
considered a career killer
people were very nervous about signing
on and now you have your movie coming
out
uh same material 50 years later 100 and
something countries all around the world
and
i just think about how much has changed
in those 50 years
it's unbelievable and and honestly
this wasn't the reason i think anyone
signed up to do it but because i think
you had to be excited about the role
and the story and the people you were
working with but it became
what we've done one of the one of the
benefits about it
that i kind of didn't see coming was
this feels like such are doing this
and and like you say in the way we're
doing it's so out
and proud and like you say being
accepted in so many different countries
like that
um it feels like a real homage to those
original guys who
in all seriousness like you say so many
of them had so much trouble finding work
even the straight ones who because they
were associated with it
half of the cast died of aids and
they were just they were the poster boys
for the
hard times that
in this case gay people were going
through to get us to where we are now
and it's just very moving to me
and i feel more personally intelligent
about my
own personal history having to go
through this
and recollect about it and think about
them
um you know it's all too easy sometimes
to take
progress for granted and and
and that's the gift of it you at a
certain level you're allowed to but i
think that
not only are you a more well-rounded
human being when you
are aware of what came before you and
the struggle that had to happen to get
to where we are
but you have information that helps you
guard against slipping back
um i i don't believe that all progress
is uh is a given once it's there i think
that we've seen
instances in which progress is taken
away
or attempted to be taken away and there
are lessons to be learned from these
people that came before us
completely i think it's a constant
battle at all times whether it be
talking about democracy
individual freedoms whatever it may be
it's too easy to slip backwards
yeah um when when you think back on the
production
was there one scene um that was
always a tricky thing for you you know
what i mean was there one
part of it or was it uh if you could
just sort of share that
yeah it was sort of different on stage
than in the movie in the movie it was
all
it didn't quite feel as much like this
but on stage
once the character that i played michael
once he took his first drink
and zach's character was there and he
began
to switch
it was always i don't know if tricky's
the right word but it was always
interesting to feel the audience
as they went and recalibrated along with
us
because you knew that there was a
certain i mean a lot of people knew the
play but
there were even then though there was a
certain element of like
what just what's happening and um
and it was exciting but it it never
landed exactly the same with them
which was a joy but it felt a little
like ice skating on a very thin
blade like you're like uh
and in a way that's exactly what's
happening you know this character is
barely
barely getting by and um and he is
reaching
he's about to hit his breaking point uh
even though he doesn't know it yet
um so that was that was always
tricky but in some ways was the main
reason to take the part
was to go through a moment like that and
put yourself in that kind of
free-fall position for a moment and see
where it landed
i thought joe did a great job with the
staging of the film and especially the
blocking
um can you talk about how you guys
worked that out in pre-production and
production
yeah well pre-production we were lucky
enough to have
a week of rehearsal on the set for
exactly that reason
so that we could really feel it out and
see what was going on
and connected to that during production
we shot
in order which is so rare in film
but we did and it was related to the
same reason once we had figured out the
staging
you start leaving a breadcrumb trail of
glasses
and bottles and cigarette butts and the
telephone and
the idea of having to reconstruct you
know moments earlier
later on it was just going to be a
nightmare and so
um but perhaps the biggest thing was
that because we had all not just the
cast but us with joe
had already spent so much time with the
material and the characters coming into
this
it wasn't rehearsal on a set like it
would normally be
for a movie you know you there was so
much
first day jitters and what have you that
were out of the way
um things that didn't have to be talked
about or figured out
and uh and that made a big difference it
really did
i'm almost out of time and i want to ask
you two questions which i'm sure you
won't answer but i'm gonna try anyway
uh what do you think michael inscribed
on the silver framed herald
well i've had my own ideas of course
which you're right i'm not gonna tell
but um somebody told me that mark told
them what was on it and i don't even
remember what it was because i don't
believe them i don't know why
i just like found that too hard to
believe but martin never told me what it
was
so i guess that goes back to him being
so
careful with actors and not wanting to
get in their head or get in their way
uh what do you think allen wanted to
tell michael i firmly believe
is is a full mystery and
michael says he's like i don't know
maybe it was about fran
maybe it was about something else and
you know the more i've thought about
that i think
in some ways alan is a character
for all the things he may or may not
mean one of the things is that
he exemplifies that that old saying of
everybody's going through something
and whether he's struggling with his
sexuality
or whether he was just leaving his wife
or whether it's something else
he is clearly hurting and um
and it leads him to a to this gathering
where he is then
lashes out and is hurtful to other
people and his old friend lashes out and
is hurtful back to him
um and i think it's just that that thing
of like
you just you never know for sure what's
going on with anybody
um and to be empathetic and try to be
understanding
for their for who they are because of
that
on that note i have to go i'm just going
to say i really mean it you did a
fantastic job with the material
thank you so much for giving me your
time thank you very much